Ron DeSantis is of course the governor
of Florida he is watching all this very
very intensely he has declared a state
of emergency in Florida tonight
he joins us right now Governor thank you
very much uh for coming on you're seeing
the bigger picture here how would you
assess Florida right now
well Tucker this is a major major storm
I mean it hit at 155 miles an hour that
is one tick below a category five but
unlike some of the category five storms
we've had this is a huge storm in terms
of its size it brought record storm
surge and Collier Lee counties and it's
continuing to churn throughout the state
and so you know you're going to end up
with many more people without power
obviously in Southwest Florida as soon
as the storm passes you know we have
emergency responders at the local level
the state has marshaled hundreds of
aircraft we have high water Vehicles we
have the capacity to go by air by land
or by sea to help people and we will do
that and that's going to need to need to
take place but then you're going to have
a major effort to restore power we have
a hundred cell towers that we can help
stand up to help do Communications we
have over 42 000 linemen and other
Personnel associated with restoring
power if you're driving anywhere in
Florida I-10 I-95 you see these trucks
coming into the state and it's been
ongoing so that's going to be the
biggest probably logistical effort in
the history of the state as soon as it's
safe to go in they're going to go in try
to get of course rescue people first
then try to stabilize the situation
restore power get fuel in there and make
sure people can communicate
so the storm came ashore in Southwest
Florida Lee Charlotte counties in there
it's hard to know exactly what's going
on there you would know how bad does it
look the damage do you think
well I think it's clearly the biggest
flood event we've ever seen in that part
of the state and that's not just Lee and
Charlotte that would be Collier he had
massive massive storm surge you have
places in those counties that have
massive standing water that of course
presents a lot of Hazards on the back
end I mean we've been telling folks be
careful once the storm goes past you
know in Hurricane Irma Tucker I had the
folks pull the numbers there were seven
deaths directly caused by Hurricane Irma
there were 77 deaths caused in the
aftermath for things like downed power
lines or misusing generators so that's
going to be a major major disaster in
terms of some of the structural damage I
think it's too soon we're getting some
intermittent reports but it's really
going to have to pass we're going to
have people out there at the local and
state level assessing the damage but my
sense is I think it's going to be one of
the biggest flood events we've ever had
what remains to be seen is just how much
damage the wind did obviously it's very
significant efficient but as you know
Tucker in that part of Florida you know
a lot of those buildings that are built
are built specifically to withstand a
category five hurricane and so we'll see
Florida building codes how did they hold
up and hopefully they held up okay
when a natural disaster like this
strikes the state it is it is common
it's I I think it's always the case that
the state receives federal aid given how
politicized things are at the moment are
you confident you're going to get the
federal support Florida needs
so I actually spoke with the president
and he said he wants to be helpful so we
did submit a request for reimbursement
for the next 60 days at a hundred
percent uh that's uh significant uh
support but it's a significant storm so
we haven't heard back from it but I'm
actually cautiously optimistic that we
do I mean as you say tucker we live in a
very politicized time but you know when
people are fighting for their lives when
their whole livelihood is at stake when
they've lost everything uh if you can't
put politics aside for that uh then
you're just not going to be able to so
I'll work with anybody who wants to help
the people of Southwest Florida and
throughout our state
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight